hey I'm Ben Shapiro with reality check a
couple of weeks ago HBO's Bill Maher got
into it with the Islamic expert and
horrifyingly mediocre actor who should
never ever ever ever ever play Batman
pen a flick over whether Islam was
indeed a violent religion here's the
exchange and you painting a brick the
whole religion with that know what let's
get down to who has the right answer
here a billion people you say all these
billion people don't hold any a billion
Rick five don't hold these pernicious
beliefs no I wouldn't
whoa they don't of course he's not alone
and taking the PC position that Muslims
the world over our tolerance and liberal
he's joined by our President Barack
Obama
his long teaches peace Muslims the world
over aspire to live with dignity and a
sense of justice wow it's just like John
Lennon's Imagine now the question isn't
whether Islam itself is violent its what
its adherents believe cuz that's what
they act upon there's plenty of violent
material in the old and new testaments
hey I'm an Orthodox Jew I read the Old
Testament a lot but believers in those
particular texts are not currently
ramming airliners into towers or
beheading journalists or mutilating
female genitalia so let's examine the
question is radicalism in the Muslim
world a tiny minority phenomenon so to
answer that question we need to define
our terms we're really not talking about
people who are active terrorists radical
beliefs are a lot broader than
terrorists and anybody who argues
otherwise is being naive or foolish or
disingenuous but terrorists draw their
moral financial and religious support
from those who are not terrorists
themselves so what are the radicals Ben
Affleck actually was right on this
they're approximately 1.6 billion
Muslims on the planet and they're from
49 different countries in terms of where
they have a majority all the populations
test by the way are from Pew Research as
of 2011 Indonesia is the world's most
populous Muslim country it's got almost
205 million Muslims living there
according to one 2009 poll showed almost
50% of Indonesians actually support
strict Sharia law not just in Indonesia
but in a lot of countries and seventy
percent blamed the United States Israel
or somebody else for 9/11 so you make
that calculation it's about 143 million
people who are radicalized you scared
yet you know what are just getting
started okay Egypt 80 million Muslims
according to that same 2009 poll it
showed that 65 percent will on strict
Sharia law in every Islamic country and
almost
many percent said that they had positive
or mixed feelings about bin Laden so
that's fifty five point two million more
radicals Pakistan has almost a hundred
and seventy nine million Muslims seventy
six percent just over three quarters one
strict Sharia law in all Islamic
countries that is another one hundred
and thirty five point four million
radicals Bangladesh not a country you
tend to think of as Muslim but there are
a hundred and forty nine million Muslims
living there as of 2013 just over a
quarter said suicide bombings or
targeting of civilians was sometimes
justified another eighty-two percent
want Sharia to be the official law of
the country and two thirds said honor
killings of women can sometimes be
justified honor killings two thirds one
hundred and twenty one point nine
million radicals Nigeria seventy five
point seven million Muslims live there
seventy one percent favored Sharia law
that's fifty three point seven million
people Iran seventy four point eight
million Muslims 83% favorite
implementation of Sharia law as of last
year so that's 62 point 1 million more
radicals Turkey has seventy four point
seven million Muslims and thirty two
percent is a moderate Muslim country
probably the most moderate Muslim
country 32% said honor killings of women
could actually be justified sometimes so
that's twenty three point nine million
radical Muslims in our moderate ally
Turkey Morocco thirty two point four
million Muslims lived there just over
three quarters support Sharia law that's
twenty four point six million radical
Muslims in Morocco Iraq thirty 1.1
million Muslims live there at seventy
eight percent say honor killings of
women can sometimes be justified that
amounts to twenty four point three
million Muslim radicals Afghanistan
twenty four million people a huge
majority seventy six percent support at
least occasionally just once in a while
on our killings of women ninety nine
percent actually want Sharia to be the
law of the land so it's like a Cuban
election over there 24 million radical
Muslims over in Afghanistan Jordan
smaller Muslim countries six point four
million Muslims right now Hamas is
enjoying with a sixty percent approval
rating so 3.8 million radical Muslims in
Jordan which is again a moderate country
Palestinian areas right we're sending
literally hundreds of millions of
dollars to the Palestinian areas we are
the American taxpayers four point three
million Muslims live in the Palestinian
areas 78% of those had positive or mixed
feelings about bin
eighty-nine percent support terror
attacks on our ally Israel 89 percent
support Sharia law we should give them a
state folks that's three point eight
three million radical Muslims how about
in the West okay let's take it to France
France four point seven million Muslims
live there a 2007 poll showed 35 percent
of French Muslims said suicide bombings
could sometimes be justified its 1.6
million radical Muslims living in France
Great Britain 2.8 million Muslims living
there 78% wanted cartoonists of Mohammed
legally prosecuted so we're talking
about 2.2 million radical Muslims in
Great Britain
how about here in the United States well
we have a very moderate Muslim
population we do 2.6 million Muslims
live here according to Pew Research 13
percent said violence against civilians
can be justified 19 percent said they
were either favorable toward al-qaeda or
just didn't know you know who knows
really
that's almost 500,000 radical Muslims
here in the United States here is the
total of the countries that we've gone
through just now 680 million thirty
thousand six hundred eighty million
thirty thousand radical Muslims and
that's out of a total population in
those countries of 940 2.4 million
Muslims total and it seems fair to
assume that similar proportions of
people in countries like say like
Algeria Syria Sudan Saudi Arabia Yemen
Tunisia Somalia and Libya are also
radicalized and if they are then well
we're above 800 million Muslims were
radicalized more than half the Muslims
on earth that's not a minority that's
now a majority and that's still not even
surveying hundreds of millions of
Muslims in other countries in other
words the myth of the tiny radical
Muslim minority is just that it's a myth
and unfortunately it's a myth that's
going to get a lot of civilized people
killed please subscribe to our YouTube
channel or click here to give a quick
donation